and then 2008 hit yeah after we had
gotten our initial money which we got
from two very wonderful major sources we
had shot most of our footage and now it
was time to start the very expensive
post production aspect of the film and
the money crunch of 2008 hit and it
isn't that everything melted down or
dried up it's just that everybody got
scared and the first thing everybody did
was tighten their purse strings so all
the potential people and organizations
and foundations that we were writing
proposals for and that we were
personally contacting and wooing all
just said sorry the doors are closed
we're not doing any funding and that put
a really big put us on the skids for a
while so we turn to the alternatives
which are small donors little
fundraisers an indiegogo campaign and we
just struggled along for a couple years
to try to get ourselves back on track
and to keep going so that the project
wouldn't you know wouldn't die so it was
it was a long and difficult time and in
this past year things have started
coming back and finally we got the money
to do our the major major expense of the
film which was our rights our music
rights and once that happened we could
finish going back to win some of those
major donors you know got scared or
weren't able to commit to you did you
ever feel like you were going to give up
on the project was that something
no you so how you know you can't give up
on your your life's work you know this
was this was a major a major work for me
and somehow I knew it would get finished
I hope that it wouldn't take eight years
but it did because you know we had that
major stop in the middle and but you
know if it had taken ten years we would
have done it so we're happy it didn't
tell me about the fundraiser so I'm
curious about that because you also used
IndieGoGo but what were some of the
fundraisers about well we did a lot of
online outreach fund raising where we
would just write a really compassionate
fundraising letter and send it to key
people and ask them who they would
suggest we send it to and through that
we started increasing our our fan base
and our funding base and you know I
would send it to a friend in San
Francisco who would send it to a friend
of hers in San Francisco who sent it to
a friend of his in San Diego who turned
out to be an heiress who came through
the large chunk of money so that was
kind of the the net that we were weaving
to to pull the money in and then we
actually did a major fundraising up at
the Playboy Mansion which you Hefner who
is one of our producers through for us
so that was very helpful so some of it
was sort of six degrees of separation
people who knew someone exactly exactly
you